la ville de rerson est devenue un
gigantesque lac englouti par les obumes
du fleuve
la force de l'eau a été-elle que le
fleuve a arraché les bâtiments et vous
le voyez ce sont leurs débris et parfois
même des toisanciers qui arrivent
maintenant dans la mer Noire à hauteur
de la ville d'Odessa eux aussi tente
tant bien que mal de survivre après la
destruction du barrage de novakarovka
pour les aider des bénévoles sont alors
recherches
nous avons déjà récupéré trois chats
aujourd'hui à bord de ce bateau
pneumatique de l'eau du pain les
garde-fontières circulent au hasard des
appels des habitants qui n'ont souvent
pas eu d'autres choix que de rester pour
le zoo de la région complètement inondé
il était déjà trop tard parmi les 260
animaux seuls les espèces aquatiques ont
pu s'en sortir dans le calme ils sont
plusieurs centaines venus apporter leur
soutien aux victimes et à leurs proches
sur une estrade installer juste à côté
des toboggans et des jeux d'enfants là
où s'est déroulé le drame
erikiotti dénonce un immobilisme en
matière d'immigration il a décidé de
passer outre le ministre de l'intérieur
et demande au Président de la République
de le recevoir sur cette question pour
éviter je cite un énième scénario à
l'eau tiède entre le l'assassinat de la
petite Lola le viol par deux clandestins
de cette vieille femme de 83 ans on a
l'impression qu'on enchaîne finalement
les monstruosités la fameuse
décibilisation le chaos migratoire nous
menace nous sommes entravés par un cadre
supranational européen et par une
jurisprudence nationale qui reprend tous
les poncifs de la gauche je vais pouvoir
vraiment choquer que d'entendre Marine
Le Pen mais aussi genre même Bardella
évidemment mais aussi Olivier Marleix
des républicains
faire tout de suite ceci sauter tout de
suite sur cette affaire pour aller
essayer de vendre leur programme
anti-immigration
en Suède on a des ministres qui
démissionnent parce qu'ils ont acheté
des tablettes de chocolat avec avec de
leur carte de crédit du parti nous on
n'a pas je trouve oui en effet que il
devrait démissionner certaines personnes
se réjouissent qu'il y ait ce genre
d'actes qui soit commis parce que ça va
leur permettre justement d'avancer leur
agenda politique non je le dis très
sincèrement quand je vois on a pris
l'exemple
ce qui s'est passé Annecy de l'autre
côté vous avez une polémique qui est
encore plus un vrai semblable on en
vient à critiquer celui qui sait
courageusement interposé parce que il
ferait le tour des cathédrales moi j'ai
lu et qui essaye de le transformer
quelque part en anti-héros parce qu'il
ne répond pas aux critères qu'on attend
d'habitude oui Henri n'est pas issu de
la diversité oui Henri c'est un militant
catholique quelque part puisqu'il en
fait il fait état de sa foi ce n'est pas
le geste
chrétiens d'un catholique français c'est
le geste de quelqu'un qui est
responsable devant
les siens devant ces frères humains et
je pense qu'il est temps aujourd'hui sur
cette question d'organiser un référendum
le peuple français a le droit d'être
consulté sur cette question qui engage
son identité sa sécurité son modèle de
protection sociale à chaque fois qu'ils
ne sont pas d'accord avec le
gouvernement le rassemblement national
propose un référendum moi je rappelle
qu'il y a moins d'un an il y a eu des
élections législatives et les élections
législatives ont débouché sur
l'assemblée tel qu'on la connaît
aujourd'hui qui ne fonctionne pas pas de
49 3 hors taxes budgétaire est-ce que ça
tient toujours
je peux vous redire si ça n'a pas été
clair que je pense que ce qui est
important dans une configuration inédite
de l'Assemblée nationale c'est en
responsabilité pour les uns et les
autres de chercher des compromis et de
pouvoir voter les textes qui sont
nécessaires pour les Français
étant donné que je pense que son cas
relève de la psychiatrie
je lui demanderai
mais d'où ça vient cette détestation des
étrangers des musulmans particuliers
immigration par exemple on pourrait
sortir 49-3 enfin je pense que ça n'est
pas la bonne méthode et on va continuer
à chercher des majorités l'ex-président
est visée par pas moins de 37 chefs
d'accusation pour avoir remporté des
documents confidentiels en quittant la
maison blanche des secrets militaires et
nucléaires convoite ici entreposés dans
son domicile en Floride en ce qui
concerne la farce que constitue
l'incubation c'est une chose horrible
c'est une chose horrible pour ce pays le
seul point positif c'est qu'elle a fait
grimper mon taux de popularité dans les
sondages vous y croyez dû les conflits
aux Archives nationales il a refusé de
les restituer malgré les relances du FBI